we'll get five suggestions and then
we'll do a little freestyle i'll come to
this kind of area first what would you
like a wrap about
game of thrones game of thrones blast
from the past what
what specifically would you like me to
wrap up in game of thrones bear in mind
that not everyone here may have seen it
and i think it's still within the kind
of you know period where we should let
people maybe watch on the remember
that's boiling too much so
incest okay cool
as he says first episode really it's
it's quite good when the show is just
like look you've got to be on board with
this
cool incest
in game of thrones people in this kind
of triangular wedge that i'm throwing up
what would you like a rap about
whales
okay so one second you said fortnight
you said whales but when you say whales
do you mean quails or the the kind of
principality of whales principality
yeah i know it's not really a princess
penalty is it but it sounds funny
are you are you welsh boya
no but i have no idea what principality
even means you have no idea what frank's
party means that's fine it's not i'm
just being silly um well i guess i guess
i guess because charles is prince of
wales in a way it must be but it means
it's a country
and wales cool and you said fortnight
again why are all our touchstones
tonight four years out of date we're
like
fortnight do you do you play fortnite
a little bit a little bit oh i mean if
you still play it now that means you
must be reasonably into it
yeah what's your favorite what do you
enjoy about fortnite i've never played
the buildings i like this this is real
mostly what you like everyone else is
running around trying to kill people and
you're like i'm trying to make a tower
why are you shooting at me
okay cool so
building in fortnite game of thrones and
incest and uh whales
people uh i guess in this shape i'm
going to say it's a trapezoid what would
you like a rap about
that
princess died yeah you've been watching
the crowd
yeah
do you you look i mean you're a pretty
blonde lady
are you is he gonna take you in a car
later
[Laughter]
um and then and people over here you
have the final suggestion and i would
like it to be
better than all of these suggestions
that's not a criticism of your quality
just that you know they're all they're
all good but i'm sure you guys can come
up with an absolute backup
dental hygiene thank you and again feels
pretty pointed given my nationality
so
building in fortnite lady dye
wales
dental hygiene
and you have to remind me of your one
it's uh it's interesting game of thrones
i feel like it's really moved away from
the fantasy hbo series and just purely
incest now
okay
well this then lovely people it's a it's
a freestyle that's a rat made up on the
spot based entirely on suggestions
you're shaking your head as if you dread
the fact this is even going to happen
you you cannot leave i'm going to put
this down here because i'm
loathe to put my phone on the floor
[Music]
um look at these rings these are very
nice and sparkly your nails are well
done as well well done please don't kill
her in a car accident she's very
she's very nice um cool this is a
freestyle about all that [ __ ] let's have
some fun
we hope you have a safe end to your
night don't crash in the tunnel like we
had with lady diana spencer yeah alive
now she dead right on the side that was
fired yeah the song of the man run in
harrods in the london if you're in the
90s yeah not a fun one i remember woke
up late 8am i went down wanted cartoons
i ate them up on the tv then i turned it
on i'm like what's this why is the head
gone wrong why she put a head through
the steering wheel i went upstairs to my
mum and dad and i peeled off the tears
of laughter the teals of sadness i said
yo mama i think something bad [ __ ] is
happening downstairs she said come swear
i said but lady diana spencer i probably
didn't know the technical surname i
probably said princess die and felt pain
she died like we had an e to a name in a
little fireball in all of the flame
caused by the paparazzis but do you mind
you talk about a death you should talk
about the landmines charity that she
cleared going down i've actually never
watched a season of the crown i prefer
all the fact that long ago dragons
coming down halflings hbo and on the
first episode of that show they push a
little boy out the top of a window why
does he spy the two little people
getting naked he's like this doesn't
make sense can't take it you're having
sex rubbing clothes but i disagree why
because you're related upon all the
family
you've got a fit sister that's how you'd
feel your life
i really wanna give a go so they put
that urge there in the show and that's
totally fine having such fun i never
fail to enjoy my food when i'm over
there in wales i get some welsh cheese
it's sent to me how do i eat it
carefully that's a fun cheese currant if
you've ever been there different kind of
cheese i'm aware they've got the little
daffodils got a lot of leeks they sound
kind of weird every time that they speak
they use a lot of ls it sounds like
they're choking can't do the action
properly cause it's broken it's kind of
weird a fact that i'll share to you if
you try and sound welch it's similar to
sounding like you are from india
therefore i don't go to the accent
moving over here yeah i know you're
attacking it the plaque that i mean at
the back of your molars a dental
hygienist just strolls over and says ah
i understand you've lost all of your
teeth cause you're from
england me pluck out all of the food
take it out here i'm like sorry this is
rude i'm paying you for a service all
the horrible dismissive attitude i don't
deserve this i need to get a better
hygienist as an offer she says hi
jealous i say i'll call a doctor she's
like that won't even help they need to
fix all your gums i'm like
i just stick at my tongue she's like
well chris yeah you think you're the
boss it's fine though why because then
she starts to floss and i don't mean
with the tiny little
[Music]
oh it's a thankless task i need some
little planks yes and i will ask you
stop shooting me with guns and missiles
it's a fun way to spend the time for a
while
[Applause]